are you a really legit a big crier i
mean have you seen the show
let's serve up some news sunny side up
people reports that lisa kudrow says
she's already shot
scenes for the special and it will be
the first time the gangs back together
in one place
and they shoot in front of a live studio
audience this spring
ross have you seen friends once twice or
a thousand times uh i have seen i've
seen all of friends and i i missed them
i mean we've been on a break
get it that's a friend reference
everybody i'm wondering do ross and
rachel have
kids is central perk still open how's
the monkey
i just saw this post on healthline
asking a vital question for our times
can
crying help you lose weight
well the answer is not really only at a
rate of 1.3
calories per minute do you burn when
you cry because by the way if it did i'd
be thin as a rail
it would be if it did i was like okay
tonight it's steel magnolias
the notebook terms of endearment i know
god i love those movies maybe throw in a
postcards from the edge uh all day er
how about a bridges in madison county
ah eddie meryl streep it's complicated
okay yeah i'll do that
something's gotta give i'll do that one
too i love something's gotta get i need
nancy meyers movie yes
and are you a really legit a big crier i
mean have you seen the show
big news in the nfl uh there's a
female referee sarah thomas is going to
make history
at the super bowl the first ever female
ref it's the first time this has ever
happened in nfl history
and on game day february 7th she'll be
the down judge
which is they used to call the head
linesman until this season when the nfl
updated it to include all refs reps
uh and i i think about little girls
watching football now
can look at the and say oh my gosh i can
be a part of this whole world what do
you think joellen
oh i think it's phenomenal especially
like so my mom was
a woman in sports she was a women's
basketball coach she was an athletic
director
at um several colleges and universities
and just like showing like women in
positions of power in the sports field
like you don't just
have to play you can also be a part of
like of the administration
of the ones making it happen the ones
literally calling the shots
i think this is phenomenal news
you know people are still going gaga
over the queen's gambit you know the
only reason i watch this show is because
drew barrymore told me too
thank you uh well and if you haven't
watched it you should and now pop sugar
reports
that not only can you watch the show you
can stay in the
harmon room at the museum hotel in
lexington kentucky
all inspired by the show and look at
that look how gorgeous these rooms are
it's fully decked out in retro decor and
the ceiling is a chess board yeah look
at that and you can
say for a queen or a king or a knight
[Music]
you